good morning John I am going to read to
you my letter to fifteen-year-old you
and yes I did just hold up my bank
statement acting like it was a letter
it's not to thank statement actually
it's an important update regarding my
overdraft coverage but before I read to
you my important update regarding my
overdraft coverage I wanted to tell you
a quick story okay last week I thought
that I had a super clever thought I was
reading fog with his comments and
someone made a reference to nerds dying
virgins which is not an uncommon
statement among the troll population
that I just wanted to respond and say
that actually I would argue that most
nerds died and I didn't know what word
to use there at first I thought
deflowered most nerds died deflowered
well I think that may be technically
true depending on your perspective it's
kind of a word has a negative
connotation like synonyms for deflower
include like corrupt and sully and dirty
sigh probably just dirty dirty is a verb
as well as an adjective and so think of
myself there is really no word for the
opposite of virgin and then I thought to
myself there should be a word for that
there should be a word for when there
isn't a word for something I love
self-referential stuff like that so I
thought it was super clever so I tweeted
a question to the world what's the word
for when there should be a word for
something but there isn't and I did not
think I was asking a serious question I
just thought that I was making a funny
statement but then because nerdfighters
are nerdfighters and nerdfighters know
this stuff two very quick tweets came in
from our Lonnie and Heather clothes
informing me that there is in fact a
phrase for that not quite a word but
it's called a lexical gap and there are
lots of lexical gaps in lots of
different languages for example in
Romanian there's no word for shallow and
so when you're translating into Romanian
you have to call it not so deep English
also has interesting lexical gaps like
the fact that we have no plural for the
word you' which is a big one and it
results in us having to invent words
like y'all and you's guys so i very
excitedly at replied both of those
people though slightly disappointed that
it was not a full word then the victoria
tweeted saying a lexical gap or a lacuna
and i was like a lacuna and so I looked
up lacunae and lacunae means a lot of
things but if you're a linguist a lacuna
is when there is no word for something
that there should be a word for so yes
there should be a word for when there
should be a word for something and there
is a word for when
should be a word for something and that
word is lacunae but if you're not
talking to a linguist and you want to be
more specific you should probably use
the phrase lexical gap that is the end
of my story and now I'm going to read to
you my letter to fifteen-year-old John
so John you're 15 and like most 15 year
olds you feel like when you're forced in
school to do math and science and
laboratory experiments you're sort of
being tortured but here's what science
does for us fifteen-year-old John it
helps us understand what to think about
and it gives us a framework for how to
think about those things the funny thing
is fifteen-year-old John Wooden year 33
you're going to write a video letter to
fifteen-year-old me saying those exact
same things about critical reading and
guess what you'll be right because 15
and 33 year old John there are lots of
ways to arrive at a place where you can
choose what to think about and you know
how to think about those things well for
you it was reading complicated books
critically for me it's statistics and
population dynamics and evolutionary
theory but the truth of the matter is to
live a good life is a good person it
doesn't matter how you got there it just
matters that you do also dump your
girlfriend I don't know who your
girlfriend is I don't know how much you
like her but dump her right now because
John in the future you are going to feel
much much better about yourself if there
is one girlfriend in your path that you
managed to dump before she dumped you
good luck with that 15-year old John 33
year old John I will see you on Friday